je pense qu'il faut mieux un confinement
territorialisée alors après qu'il soit
au niveau régional départemental
je ne sais pas je laisse les experts les
épidémiologistes et le conseil
scientifique se prononcer mais il est
vrai que je ne vois pas pourquoi on re
confinerait notamment des départements
des régions de l'ouest de la france qui
sont peu impacté aujourd'hui qu'il
observe une diminution de la propagation
du virus
il faut éviter ce que ce virus se
propage et donc se focaliser sur les
départements ou régions où métropoles
les plus concernés sur un confinement
qui doit durer dix à quinze jours à plus
c'est l'objectif est de ralentir la
progression de l'épidémie et surtout de
respecter les perspectives qui ont été
données aux françaises et aux français
il y a quelques semaines et donc la
proposition est de dire mais pourquoi ne
pas profiter de cette fin d'année 2020
où les enfants ne sont pas les comme les
restaurants et cafés sont fermées ou les
commerçants ont pu réouvrir pour les
achats de noël de prévenir la rentrée
2021 et de confiner pour éviter cette
troisième vague qui aujourd'hui est
prédit par beaucoup de spécialistes